i
i do wonder about this particular
problem and maybe you can speak to it
of how smart contracts can
take over certain industries in a sense
or how
certain industries can convert their
sets of agreements
into smart contracts which is you
mentioned sort of talking to dave from
the bank
you know many of our laws many of our
agreements are
currently through natural language
through words and so there is a process
of
mapping that has to occur in order to
convert
the legal agreements legal contracts of
today
to smart contracts that by the way ai
may be able to help with
but as a by way of question how do you
think would convert
the legal contracts on which many
industries currently function today or
not even legal contracts but ambiguous
kind of agreements
maybe they're loose sometimes into more
formal
deterministic agreements that are
represented by smart contracts
so i i think there's two um maybe two
sides
to this um i think the first one is
actually not a huge problem
where you have things like the is the
master agreement for derivatives or you
have these agreements
that basically already reference a
system somewhere
right like for example many legal
agreements already accept e-signature
and so they're saying hey i'm going to
use this computing system over here
around signatures
and i'm going to consider and there's
laws around that and there's clauses
that say e-signature is good enough for
this agreement
i actually don't think this is a big
problem for the vast majority of legal
agreements
that use systems already right so what
you'll do is you'll swap out
one repository or one or one set of
contr system of contract
settlement and you'll just say hey this
blockchain system over here
is my new system of contract settlement
whatever it says
is the state of the agreement instead of
you know the centralized
system over there right and and so
there's actually a huge amount of
agreements that are already
able to to do that and i think we'll
we'll do that
i think there's another side to your
question which is the
amount of agreements that are very
ambiguous that can be turned into smart
contracts
and i think the limitation there is is
twofold
first of all like like you said earlier
the highly reliable smart contract and
the and the
lack of opaqueness and the clarity of
smart contracts
is is is very um high and very powerful
and very clear
and it's in my opinion going to be much
much easier to take
a smart contract and turn it into a set
of natural language
explanations and just say hey um you
know
this is what this does right so i think
that many contracts are and even now in
decentralized finance and d5
and decentralized insurance they're
basically being rebuilt in this format
and and and that rebuilding will make
them clearer like you said
and then restating those in natural
language and explaining to people well
you know
whether there's this it'll i think it'll
actually be a lot simpler to explain to
people what the contract is about
saying mapping smart contracts it's a
natural language i didn't even think
about that so that's that's
you're saying that's doable and natural
and easy to do
because there's so much clear right
there's there's that forced clarity that
you talked about
i i think the second um aspect of this
problem is the nuance around
what contracts can be made unambiguous
and i think that comes down to
often comes down to proving what
happened which is where oracle networks
and decentralized oracle networks and
chain link would come in
and our experience there is you know
quite extensive over the many years that
we've worked on many different contract
types
i think what it fundamentally comes down
to
is whether there is data so we're not
going to be
able to make a hybrid smart contract
about whether somebody painted your
house the right color blue
we're just not going to be doing that
because there's no data feed that tells
us that your house was painted blue or
that it was the right color of blue
you know unless somebody sets up a drone
with a color analysis
tool and they generate that data which
by the way could be possible right
they could there could be if there's
enough demand then the service would be
created that has drones flying around
that's telling you about the colors of
you know all this kind of stuff so if
there's
actual demand that that would be created
and because because there'll be value to
connect that data feed to the smart
contracts and so on
i i think i think you have it
unbelievably right because there there
are
already insurance companies that use
drones to monitor construction sites
from overhead
and see how many people are wearing hard
hats and if the percentage of people
wearing hard hats isn't sufficiently
high
then you know the policy is voided and
so in that case
there is a data source and that data
source can be put into a hybrid smart
contract
so the limitation of hybrid smart
contracts is is there a data source or a
set of data sources to create definitive
truth
to settle the contract and eliminate
ambiguity
and then as you said i think as people
realize that smart contracts are a
format
in which they can form agreement about
things like that insurance product
around you know how many people are
wearing hard hats if i'm the
construction site owner
well you know i would really like a
guarantee that your insurance policy is
going to pay me out
if everyone is wearing hard hats and
in that case there is demand for the
data and people will generate the data
and i actually think the insurance
industry is interestingly a precursor of
this because they're so data driven
you already see insurance companies
paying
iot companies to put data into their
customers infrastructure
at the cost of the insurance company to
generate the data that the insurance
company uses to make a policy for the
customer
so you basically already have people who
really
want to price data into their agreements
when they're sufficiently high value
paying
for their own customers to get data
sensors into their infrastructure
and i think as smart contracts become
more of a requested
format or data-driven contracts become
more of a format
there will be a growing demand about
proving what happened through data so
it'll be motivating totally new data
fees being created
by the way the the insurance industry
broadly
the revolutions there would be huge i've
worked quite a bit with autonomous
vehicles semi-autonomous
and just vehicles in general the
insurance industry that by the way
makes a huge amount of money but is
using very crappy data fees
uh revolutionizing
how like not by crap i mean very crude
like literally the insurance is based on
things like age gender like basic
demographic information
as opposed to really high resolution
information about you as an individual
which you may or may not want to provide
so you can choose from an individual
perspective to provide a data feed and
there
like the the um
the power of to the indiv
to enable the individual to empower the
individual
could be huge because ultimately smart
contracts motivate the use of data
the creation of new data feeds but
leveraging
the the whatever service it provides
in truth as opposed to some kind of very
loose notion of who you are so that
i'm not again not sure how that would
change things but
in terms of the fundamental experience
of life
because i think we all rely on insurance
not just in business but in life
and grounding that insurance and more
and more
accurate representation of reality might
just have transformative effects on
society
well just to mention one quick thing
that you said where i noticed another
trust issue
you said the user might not want to
share their data yes
so what you could actually do and what
we've already worked on is
you can have a smart contract that holds
the data and
evaluates the data of the user without
sharing it with the insurance companies
and the insurance company knows that the
smart contract will evaluate it
according to the policy they don't need
the data
and the and and the user can provide the
data
knowing it'll never touch the insurance
company because it's only provided to
the smart contract
and suddenly you've solved another trust
issue because an autonomous piece of
code can evaluate information
separately from the interests of both of
the counterparties
and so this is the recurring theme i
think you're seeing this recurring theme
where
there's a trust issue people can't use
the system they can't collaborate
they can't share information that would
make a better agreement for both of them
they can't
you know solve a risk in their daily
life they can't participate in a market
they can't have a bank account because
nobody will give it to them because
you know they can't give it to them in
that legal system
and once you have an autonomous piece of
code
that can also know what's going on
thanks to oracle networks and that
combination of the code and the oracle
network for the hybrid smart contract
the same pattern just recurs it's it's
really the same
pattern and and this is why i keep
saying trust issues it's because
i basically almost every contractual
trust issue that i see
where there is a piece of data to prove
and settle the trust issue
in a way that works for both parties um
there is no reason not to use an
autonomous highly reliable
contract and piece of code and um
i have to tell you i've seen this in in
a lot of different industries i've seen
it
insurance ad networks global finance
global trade
those are all multi-trillion dollar
industries and then there are there are
other smaller industries
like even even one of the first smart
contracts we worked on many years ago
was for search engine optimization firms
where
they would tell you hey i'm going to
raise your search engine ranking
give me the money and people wouldn't
want to give them the money because they
they never
knew if they were going to do it and
then the search engine firm doesn't want
to do any work thinking they'll never
get any money
so we just initially even came up with a
system where you could put bitcoin into
a smart contract
and it would be released based on
whether the search rank of a website
got to a certain level on google for a
certain keyword right
and so the trust problem was solved but
it's just the same story right it's kind
of like trust issues around ai
trust issues around financial products
trust issues around insurance trust
issues around
social media whatever it is i i think
that's what um people looking at this
industry
really need to understand and once they
do understand they realize what this is
all about
this is about redefining how
everyone collaborates with everyone
about everything where we can prove
something through data
you